uh so in this history of capitalism that
uh uh that bus renovassan recounts he
talked about one of the most dramatic
episodes being
henry ford's
elevated salary for model t
manufacturing workers uh where it made
headline news it was essentially double
uh the customary salary
and it would enable
a worker the average worker to be able
to buy the model t
uh
based on three months of income and so
this was a game changer um and i was
trying to imagine what a modern day
equivalent of that would be like it
would be something like i i guess like
what is the the fort of today uh maybe
it's amazon and maybe amazon wakes up
tomorrow jeff bezos they actually have
the money to do this so this would be a
fascinating exercise uh it would be like
if they woke up tomorrow and said hey
everyone gets paid 30 bucks an hour like
like twice of a prevailing wage
now i think most people look back fondly
on
the
model t manufacturing wage being higher
they see that as something of an emblem
of the progression of capitalism of
american industry do you think that's
right uh and do you think that it's
possible that something like that could
happen today i don't i i feel like it
couldn't um but if it did happen would
it be desirable
well it wouldn't maybe you could argue
have some inflationary impact i wouldn't
worry about that if if amazon or apple
or other people said look we're going to
make sure that all our employees get
paid uh i don't know 25 an hour or
whatever some higher than minimum wage
is uh that might be beneficial it would
set a trend off for the country might be
inflationary so it's hard to know right
now it's hard to believe though but the
minimum wage united states is still
about seven and a half dollars an hour
yeah even 15 is an effective doubling 15
but that was over four years uh that
going to 15 and that was the proposal so
it's amazing that the minimum wage is
still so low uh as it is um i i i don't
know whether there's an entrepreneur
today who is willing to do the kind of
things that henry ford did i hope so but
there's a limited number of individuals
who are able to do it to do that you
have this this global perspective and
this is something i was uh i was eager
to ask you about based upon something
that also that
um that business on said
he was trying to compare the chinese
model of capitalism to the american
model and he said something that would
make a lot of americans i think fall out
of their chair he said the communists
seem to be very good at capitalism
and he talked about an example of
thousand dollar drones that china is
able to manufacture with ease we've seen
it now even with some of the drugs and
testing
where a lot of that stuff is
manufactured overseas in america
and he says that the bulk of our
economic policy is determined by the
consumer market which is a mistake and
you should have some policy that's uh
that's directed towards things other
than low prices uh and what consumers
want
um you guys invest everywhere carlisle
just tries to find great opportunities
and firms how optimistic are you about
the american model of capitalism
relative to let's say the chinese okay
look the american model of capitalism
has obviously worked for a couple
hundred years and done quite well the
chinese model is different and it's got
some
improvements over ours and has some
deficiencies
there's a new book out by somebody you
probably know
um and ray dalio called the changing
world order
and in it he basically says that the
chinese motto of capitalism probably
will prevail over the next
50 years or so over the american model
because china's a rising power and its
form of capitalism probably will
ultimately be uh more successful than
ours and that's that's a short-circuit
way of saying what he said but
essentially the american motto is going
down a bit because we borrowed too much
money
we're not as hard-working maybe as we
used to be all the things you probably
know about
and so i think the chinese model
shouldn't be dismissed by americans as
as ridiculous it wouldn't suit our our
freedom our interest in freedom but the
chinese motto of communism or capitalism
does have some benefits that has made
their economy you know
basically the biggest in the world
so given your
uh
conversations with everyone under the
sun in our nation's capital i probably
should dig into your dinners with
members of congress more deeply because
they sound fascinating uh
i feel like you started out
your trilogy of books
um kind of uh
a bit more optimistic
that
it seems like the concern level has
risen it could just be because the order
of the interviews as presented look
anybody that's an entrepreneur and
you've been an entrepreneur by
definition is somewhat optimistic
because if you were pessimistic you
would just get in a hole you wouldn't do
anything so by nature i'm optimistic but
i'm also realistic that we have some
challenges in this country there are
challenges that people of my economic
background are not going to be suffering
from as much as people who are lower in
the economic totem pole so um it's not a
perfect system but i you know i'm now at
an age i'm much older than you where i'm
trying to get things done
in my lifetime and i'm not trying to do
things that i think aren't going to get
done in my lifetime so i'm working on
different things and you you your
project is going to take 10 20 30 years
to get maybe having a
fruition and you might be successful in
30 years i don't have 30 years to give
to something so i i'm trying to do
different things
well that's one thing i admire about you
uh that you're trying to get it done
quickly um so if there's something that
you would want
our listeners uh to dig into
to maybe check out volunteer contribute
uh like what are ways that people can
get engaged try to do something
to make your neighborhood your city your
country something better than it was
before just don't you don't have to be
you know solving all the problems of the
world or you don't have to be securing
cancer just find something you can
contribute to and you'll feel better
about yourself and you'll probably live
longer because you'll feel better about
yourself secondly read more about what's
going on in the world and read books
books focus the brain better than
internet uh you know memos or something
like that read books
read more
um and try to figure out how you can
contribute to your society and therefore
think what you can do to make the world
a slightly better place in your 80 or 90
years on the surface of this earth
because we're here a relatively short
period of time
[Music]
you